[Music]  you know obviously you're the  Bachelorette yes what you don't know is  the Bachelorette starts right now  [Applause]  after teasing a historic surprise during  after the final rose  bachelor producers stunned the audience  and new bachelorette  rachel lindsay by bringing out a few  contestants from her upcoming season  like Demario you don't have to meet  anymore guys I'm the guy for you and  Blake you look good you smell good I'm  so I'm so excited to you Dean  I'm ready to go black and I'm never  gonna go back and Derek  et spoke with the stunning 31 year old  attorney last month where she revealed  what she's looking for in a husband  I need a funny guy I need you to be able  to talk sports bad breath the  deal-breaker and then I need a guy who  knows exactly what it is that he wants  you  you